Okay, so here's a quiz for you Micheal, here's the
setup, you ready? You've got N data points. The learner
that you're going to use over your subsets is a
zeroth order polynomial. The way you're going to combine the
output of the learners is by averaging them. So, it's
just what we've been talking about so far, and your
subsets are going to be constructed in the following way. You
uniformly randomly picked them and you ended up with N different
subsets or disjoint, and each one has a single point
in it, that happens to be one of the data points.
>> Okay i think i get that
>> Right, so if you look over here on your left
you got a graph of some data points and this is
one subset This is another subset, that's another subset, that's another
subset, that's another subset, that's another
subset, that's another subset, got it.
>> Yeah, now what do you want to know about it.
>> Now what I want to know is when you do your
ensemble learning you learn all these different,
you learn all these different rules and then
you combine them ,what is the output going to be? What does the ensemble output?
>> And you want a number?
>> I want a description and if the answers a number that's a
perfectly fine description. But I'll give you a hint, it's a short description.
>> A short description of the answer. Okay, I'll think about it.
>> Alright.